[Applause]
[Music]
it's April 2020 the only real reason the
date matters is that we're all living
through a pretty exceptional moment in
time
millions of us around the world are
sitting at home practicing social
distancing and we were curious how were
other people feeling so we reached out
to our filmmaking community and spoke
with eight filmmakers in eight countries
to document their home isolation stories
[Music]
my name is Beryl
I'm a senior producer at great big story
and I have been in home isolation for 21
days and I know that I'm not alone I've
been in social isolation for five days
I've been in social isolation for 16
days now I've been in social isolation
for 24 days we are on day 25 of the
quarantine it's been 29 days me llamo
Eleanor Dini be aroma so knowin is or
amento so Charlotte Atlanta Georgia
Salaam America so Tony has some sake I'm
a shot Taliban gauge market economy
latina has same hotel Connie which is a
beijing and tianjin sure what the lucy
and that's work early
[Music]
pretty sure that the situation in
Hungary is similar to a lot of places in
the US I think what we're realizing is
around the world in terms of this
contagion and the spread that doesn't
really know any borders the whole of
Spain has been effectively locked down
with forbidden by the government from
going outside unless it's to go to the
shops or the pharmacy you risk receiving
a fine of up to two thousand euros if
they catch you walking around in pairs
or in groups so I'm in isolation at my
family's house I'm out the back in the
tent that you can see behind me I
arrived in Australia just after the
government announced that everybody who
arrived internationally had to
quarantine for 14 days
we were ordered by our government here
in the Philippines to be in an enhanced
home quarantine Natalia to table cod and
you stood the north the acid promised an
president a karateka about the Silencio
of been a cozy Tonto
we've seen enough in Spain and Italy
that this is the right thing to do so he
since atmospheric I should say eating
cold there's a little freezing now a
woman a person event o to say so gonna
go is in place you come talk away
Thank You Julian Union City it to touch
a usual pointman told which are higher
power true true we are pumped are you
know were made in Peleliu city annotated
by the Italian Tata Safari montage Jimmy
Dolan Dolan Valentino H Balkan of the
hotel key fellas Adamo a homonym debemos
ooh well I'm on the edge Verona here in
New York City the situation is pretty
much the same the city is in essence
closed and we have all been asked to
stay indoors in this new world we've had
to create our own new normal I start my
morning with coffee business as usual
[Music]
the day starts with coffee lots of
coffee I make coffee we usually make
enough coffee to drink all day 2 euros -
loke be darn shame the harder some
Connie there are food Russian 3 for our
own good Rancho epic random cafe I'm a
teacher normally and all of my classes
have moved online so at the moment I
wake up at about 7:30 a.m. to teach an
hour long
thou shalt see laiona bangle quicker or
it's a chalet it's it shits outside
right now all the days are generally
blurring into one another I'll get up
I'll make myself a coffee read the news
which at the moment is you never know
what's happened overnight there's cat
you know watch the cat wonder by I'm
lucky I am able to work from home but my
husband and my one-bedroom apartment has
become two people's home office and
shared living space so we're just trying
to not step on each other
hey I I'm in isolation with my boyfriend
Tim can you stop clowning I'm not me no
no I'm like trying to focus on the
camera and stuff please don't take it
personal okay so my dad is here my
sister thank you and my niece my dad 73
though and is in high-risk group so it's
really important that for these 14 days
there is as much social isolation as
possible so yeah I'm sleeping in the
tent and an outside all the time so
noisy at our core look he's my companion
a nostril after John man Barham Saddam I
mean I've had a personal so far I'm in
home isolation unfortunately with my
wife Sarah she's behind the camera right
now
Sierra's right behind the camera right
now
sayers behind the camera right now so
I'm in social isolation with my husband
Richard and my daughter Alex who's
making this film della daddy your water
Baba
mama Luke Dorris way love will always
ensure you're holding down the shower
I'm currently in home isolation with my
mom and my dad being here at home with
my parents can get annoying sometimes
but for the most what I'm just saying
the truth
no this one's starting with it being
here at home with my parents can be a
little bit annoying sometimes but for
the most part it's actually kind of nice
so all of us stuck in our homes have
come up with ways to pass the time
[Music]
looking in my fridge it's a right mess
[Music]
our days centre which we get to eat what
should we cook you may take to walk
early daddy may either in the paint
roller that was not on the Megan t-shirt
we've been trying to use this as an
opportunity to perfect some Spanish
dishes today we'll be cooking to NOLA
it's a Filipino dish it's a chicken soup
with vegetables it's really good and
tasty a crystal mentality slowly I'm
getting old so I do next even Apple
artists bendiness bleeping doing similar
Pat's on the roof my living room has
become my gym there's some exercise
equipment here so I ride on the exercise
bike there's a rowing machine you know
occasionally you know do a row on the
rowing machine you have a person we look
up on YouTube and then we just follow
her there has been a lot of wine
drinking have that noise I will say I've
been doing face times with my parents
and having happy hours with them yes
I've connected with people you know by
having I guess a video chat happy hour
well 14 passionate championship or she
could be a who your local shows either
yeah they should Hama Kayoko Leah want a
eighty Roger time colossi empathic which
is a belief on you've had no balls each
a boyish motuhake Mahalo Monica quality
open anchovy
we've been playing online Dungeons &
Dragons rummy Cup is a big one we'd all
love rubbing up my parents liked to play
table games especially Scrabble but
let's be honest a lot of time is spent
like this
[Music]
we're all going through an unprecedented
moment in history creating these
routines at home feels so important
because what's happening outside we have
no control over
[Applause]
la casa que Mis per entity pure non
superior anantapur day cuando esto
senior I can't walk outside I can't see
my friends I can touch the shops when I
went to which is obviously which is
obviously quite unnerving my fiance and
I were supposed to be getting married
this year but I'm not sure when we'll be
getting married anymore
I suppose really I'm actually anxious
and scared for my whole country was
Asian
Johan in it had a research in Toronto
course a shirt in the future how the
girl is Ito and hurtful to the short
away me who trans and order tickets it
had a donkey naive Donahue Gina
Kojiro showed how Honda
[Music]
Queen Charlotte a Lombardo fish mother
man Harris coderdojo cream kava kava
kava sub Escobedo and Xiao Zhang Mian
came on his own
Adam mm Adama has some character changer
Lucy showed on estado da da da mo muto
not sonali governor custody' three
Johnny D Silencio Silencio total a pair
[Music]
/ - Timothy catches on or d'italia they
also have to figure out how can we keep
on living how can we keep on being human
beings in talking to everybody we
learned that while we may be alone in
our homes we aren't actually alone from
this isolation has come community in
some really surprising ways you know
society is not made up of a bunch of
individuals it's made up of thousands
and thousands of layers of relationships
and their vital for life
[Applause]
[Music]
in a way this situation has brought the
world a little bit closer together
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been reading about the you know the
big and the small acts of kindness that
people have been involved in
[Music]
yeah I'm not ashamed to say that
sometimes it makes me cry every night
everybody comes together at 8 p.m. and
does this big applause and this big
cheer and bangs their pots and pans to
say thank you to health workers and
social workers and people still working
in shops and it's really overwhelming
and really emotional and really exciting
and really lovely and I burst into tears
yesterday and I couldn't really explain
why I think it's just because we have no
contact with the outside world and then
it's this really beautiful and really
unusual moment of everybody coming
together and demonstrating that we're
all in this together
Mac we're the same purana qila Terry
Johnson you do not ask a video loop
around the center Louie tutti Jordan II
vintage or no and Calise samhita for a
concerto Allah SWA
fizzer Monica yeah with the return to
three personal tastes and man and color
to be from the jockey ball Chuckie he
can taco Louie well today is actually
quite a special day it's my 64th
birthday I'm very much hoping that I'm
gonna have a very nice meal cooked
tonight and this some champagne in the
fridge our land ladies live across the
courtyard from us when we got here we
didn't know any Hungarian we still don't
speak a ton and we'll see them across
the window and we'll wave and sometimes
they'll get into conversations and
they'll start shouting things in
Hungarian to us we'll try to figure them
out from far away you know we all feel
like we're kind of in this situation
together
no to say Josh Nehalem oh honey you know
notice a fiction Conan but a moment
Iranian yes sir yes sir shoddy hisses nd
geardo body but in sauna massage having
Holika diamond hoop coney man to d sharp
a la sala no as I hate saying it become
soft we have sinned [ __ ] now another
Stan goddamn [ __ ] oh boy yet dude
economizing Hester who hurt yangjia a
lon
her ladonia food nice Almonte me to
Amalapuram L hope Connie before this all
happened
time felt linear or at least it made
more sense what happened a week ago
feels like a lifetime ago
and time is something that we always
felt like we never had enough of and now
it's as if we have nothing but time and
it feels so strange
we know that eventually our doors will
open back up and we as a world will
start to heal so given this extra time
what have we done with it auntie name
name shake okay you're cool baby that
was my fiction come help me or down ha
down ha miles away Isaac on over there
mr. hamster I'm so far huh you know my
whole behind you feeling us a cavity in
time in Valentina Tom on short yeah
Ashley Bagheera
but her mama no damn okay nothing to
something more that perilous Cola jumba
jookiba become jealous corsola
as UK hamster option yacht gala thank
you but mr. Patterson omotchama tuna
Tommy talk about to Tony orderly
hey zibolski mojito unanimity welcome
attention pendulum on control so in
since I was out water she tear me away
who sounded like a high efficiency taco
hides Troy teacher hi-ho hiatus you come
over to the exhibition quad everything's
gonna be okay it'll be different and it
won't be okay for everybody but
everything's gonna be okay
during a time like this you realize the
importance of the people who work at the
grocery store you know they're as
essential to all of our survival right
now as doctors and nurses I think it's
really nice first we'll learn how to
slow down and not be frantically rushing
around all the time
this experience has taught me how
incredibly fortunate I am and I've got
loved ones who love me it makes you
appreciate the very simple things in
life which is not a bad thing it's
definitely a time of rejuvenation and
times that I can kind of just reflect
and be excited about what I'm going to
be doing after this time of Solitude sa
beautiful miss same monotonous and isla
de los party o in the stamp a capital K
quanta better contact the water they
always cantata and officially pensaron
little alia Robbins okay seguramente
basic in the psychology remember that
she's been carefully restored
you
[Music]